hey guys I'm great and I'm John well
we're back at it again the real rejects
hey John yeah what is it what's going to
a few people requested this first person
I found Jason underscore Todd underscore
is all caps Batman hey can you react a
Batman vs Iron Man arcade mode please
resistance hot Batman that happened
someone don't dump on me on the spot I'm
wearing a Deadpool shirt kukuku
tomorrow will do to that you know John
anyone that gives a DC movie a bad
review is a marvel fan boy yeah nothing
is subjective I should know are you
racoon pretty compatible that episode 6
I haven't seen episode 1 through 5 this
is going to make sense
okay go read oh all charged up and ready
to roll haha that's 210 versus 425 but
that's not accurate
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa good graphics whoa we gotta watch
that video too
Mike so long oh dude
why are you watching this so Paul Jarvis
I don't want to disturb you this late
but I've located the bank brothers try
to make handle it he has school tomorrow
so what can I do I'm watching a film
right now first Orban probably in bank
Nuala okok Natasha anyway they can't
handle what's up for parachute Gervais
right two ways a little lazy superhero
put them Candlewood crimes but happy say
[Music]
this is a much better arcade they were
pretending to be Emperor isn't it
goodbye Batman like it Batman and bank
robber with Tony why are you flying of
what exactly you ever think you see how
to be a good Jackman we watching that's
a German I did not but that can we go
back home I would really love to who
just arrived at location they are hiding
somewhere in that abandoned Russian
shipyard great this looks like a really
cool cutscene like I want to play them
Jarvis you see anything Bobby don't set
he wants me to scan the area
yes you in the area what's over there hi
right two ways how the huge advocate has
been located
okay great
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
whoa okay this looks really creepy that
is something Tony Stark will say there
you are
all right let's take you guys back to
jail back
that's creepy too it's pretty good
it's a be suddenly panicking this place
really freaks me out
Jarvis do you schedule Nelson here whoa
[Music]
whoa what's your problem Batman I'm
scared Terry no no the bat of Gotham
gabon to pick who knows a guy
[Music]
whoa how did he handle that much oh
pretty through a wall aha Jarvis can we
see it's got a form several six
instances it appears the adult on any
official shield over those omegas below
there you and I have put the shaft it
would screw it up here these guys but
I'm dead utility for this is not your
problem well it is now so here we go let
me not really hate it yeah
Oh
[Music]
look you guys watch out
I kill Batman
[Music]
not the wait can you give it all that
way could be right there to get that
mantlet still there mr. Wayne we play by
to be gamble Wow
call it mr. Wayne
[Music]
why Batman have gone it was enchanting
below 10% do that go in huh stop out of
the billionaire it's not wasting my time
gone
I think he took lines from Kevin Connor
love love love the actual choreography
oh [ __ ] you're talking about that oh
that's a good dark a much darker turn
you've got your toy and I got mine
yes
he just scary Batman yeah very funny
those bars
all right we'll do it we'll follow you
is differently for like all of sudden
[Music]
Eliot crossly
Niklas Cortez for voicing Jarvis and
Alfred okay someone Disney Batman uses a
really good Kevin Conroy
[Music]
well I've never seen the mighty racoon
before what what up post-credits oh
we're going to take on Mary Allen I was
like a Pixar commercial so they have
like Buzz and Woody show up and it's not
part of the actual movie was a black
background that was really cool
well animated I mean oh I kind of wanted
to see a little bit more like the 8-bit
arcade stuff I love that I don't know
histology from playing arcades when I
was younger and today Sherman Oaks
Capitol Park you might be able to catch
me there sometimes I thought it was
really well made video it's novel to see
those two dudes crossover yeah same
universe and and it's it is like a
really complicated fanfiction yeah it is
really good fanfiction I I don't know I
feel like with a lot of these things you
know we're Batman versus someone who can
probably most likely defeat him bemmon
is my jam he's my OD [ __ ] you
know an Iron Man of course I want to see
Batman be Iron Man so I'm satisfied with
that at the same time though I'm like
Iron Man probably has a few more things
he could have done though and tried
instead of just a punches and a few guys
like cannons and she had a little if
that meant you know what that is you
know you know is this batwing and
[ __ ] just annihilated with boys so I
know you do too same thing and I'm just
saying Iron Man held back a little bit
and I wasn't really happy about that
yeah what's up - what's up Tony what are
you doing man
you trying to lose you take my knee go
down with it come on member you know I'm
kind of with you like I prefer Batman to
Iron Man generally speaking so yeah it's
like I want bats to win also - just the
physics like they bothered to establish
like the Iron Man has like 200 pounds on
him yeah and those punches like I'm I'm
just punching yeah I ran punches baton
in the face then exstrophy or even feel
a metal and [ __ ] I said I want Batman
around I'm thinking like I remember
obably would have really damaged Bruce
Wayne any punch to the face like that
which is because Batman doesn't have
super strength no [ __ ] kill him
yeah yeah Superman punch it one time in
the
EVs you would have been not the plug a
yeah I'm pretty sure everyone can just
like punch through his head like some
kind of pump even with Batman's punching
Iron Man suit I can buy that more than
man I getting punched in the face any
maybe his gloves are reinforced or
something but like baby still gonna
[ __ ] hurt ya there oh they're not
that thick for the fantasy of it all I
mean this is super cool like in to
admire the animation see even though we
want a Batman to win we can still see
some things that were kind of flawed
about Iron Man losing you happy we're
not just going DC or marble here
recovering both sides of the spectrum
yeah man Equal Opportunity criticisms
yes but you know you got to read some
comments on this got a reason coming
Iron Man should win so what Batman is
too overrated that man is an [ __ ] he
has got an [ __ ] in this video famines
a killer this one which I only do it in
New York City or wherever Iron Man is
currently at this point if it story yeah
yeah well I'm also just like how we got
another Beach other you do a lot of [ __ ]
that's noticeable him you guys are a
costume well Tony Stark was a little
Deadpool like kinda he calls and Hugh
Jackman I was watching The Wolverine
footage how does he know it's batman
bruce wayne agents Bruce Wayne yeah I
was owning out of that too because he's
not in the system yeah just leave him
everyone ever seen him before you know
so what are the rules of this universe
of arcade mode of Batman vs Iron Man
we just got we gotta ask the question we
got adequate questions what a different
things that aren't as relevant as they
need to pick you the beauties this is a
really very cool very cool very cool I
would watch the next movie were
overthinking it a little bit hey well
you know for the size of what it is yeah
but they're also fair point though so
what are you gonna do we're gonna do a
patreon shout out but subscribe to the
real rejects reason to Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum House and the real rejects and
we're going to do a patreon of the day
shout out only only home remember that
Metal Gear Solid video Oh crabs that
the cowbells nice stab dragon Hey
totally jumbled we gave you a mention in
the video but I realize when I was
watching the video back pari Nemiroff
kind of interrupted me and I didn't get
to finish your shoutout so we're going
to finish your shoutout totally jump
totally jumbled what are you jumbled up
what's going on at your life are you
having a hard time balancing work women
those are usually the only two things
that they cover on the show friends I'm
assuming those are your problems - even
when Ross and Rachel have a baby you
can't forget the advocate seems like a
very mellow parenting Ross I was a son
that he's never raised the most oh he's
hanging out inside the guy you totally
jumbled I don't understand why you would
give your scenes such up it's just a
negative connotation like we have a
positive title real rejects you know
well I totally jumbled jumbled jumbled
aren't just bad by design I think
totally jumble it could be your nickname
yes I think that in every state in
summation she said that's what I think
this is your account that you donated
$30 I did every month our patreon to me
so $30 I mean you're gonna be part of
the Google hangout to you buddy
that means yeah we'll come hang out with
us come talk to us in Pride on the
Internet on the other glog you know in
private it's a private credit
conversation private connection
[Music]